i feel like a natural question is going
to come up this freaking covet with the
wuhan lab the bat
was it in a lab was it in a bat was it
in a wet market do you have strong
feelings on this where do you think i
think it's a strong feeling where do you
think it started when i first heard
about it it was the same thing wuhan wet
markets which you know kind of sort of
makes sense when you put it in two and
two together i look at stuff from a
nature's perspective you know so um
nature's been on a decline for decades
it hasn't been getting any better it's
been getting worse and worse and worse
you know so if nature has a defense
mechanism against a plague which could
be possible humans you know even though
we are from nature and a part of nature
we're growing at a rapid rate where
everything else is decreasing at a rapid
rate deforestation you're talking about
station infringing on their harvesting
over i mean everything cutting down
livestock all types of stuff is
happening you know but earth is big
you know we really dispersed ourselves
and you know became more eco-friendly
and sufficient of our resources that
were taken i think we can do good but
nature
ain't having what's happening right now
to it you know so
something like you know different wet
markets around the world you guys know
what a wet market is right it's a it's a
black market it's a i wouldn't even call
it a black market it's a part of culture
in other parts of the world that are the
norm it's like us going to publix or
kroger or walmart to get our food they
have spots like japan and japan
china
vietnam
africa i mean everywhere south america
there are wet markets
not really in europe you know africa
yeah here's a picture of a wet market so
i mean they just they sell
and for they survive they catch
everything yeah and if it moves they
catch it and they sell it and they eat
it so i mean here's some images of of a
wet market with all sorts of funky
different animals but back to their
initial question with
these bats
and what caused potentially covid
do you think it was actually from a bat
or do you think it came from a lab from
what they're saying they said that in a
wet market what do you think there was
there was there was a a system of cages
right one was a pangolin one was a bat
one was a possum and something on the
bottom was chickens right and all these
things pissed and [ __ ] and pussed and
died and all the nasty stuff that
accumulate on the bottom
someone took one of those bats or one of
those things in the bottom yeah
boiled it ate it got sick spread a new
virus but they already proved it that it
was not it was men made no like i don't
think anything's been proven yet that's
sort of the big dilemma is like china
won't let people in to basically
investigate and if you know anything
about china's authoritarian communist
regime
you're not an ex exactly to get straight
answers but there is
the assumption that it did come from a
wet market and then there also is
the opinion that it could have been from
a lab not saying that they purposely put
it out there
but basically as as you're explaining
this this wet market the bat the chicken
the possum this that's a good way to
cover something up and they make it
a very scary version but you know they
make movies on them you know i watched a
movie from 2011 that they made and it
was basically everything that happened
and everything they said so it's like
how did the pandemic happen in 20. 20 22
but they made a movie about the same
exact stuff in 2011 just
well bill gates has been talking about
stuff like this about uh you know being
weary of a pandemic anyway yeah so
you're
the button is down you're thinking that
if you could put odds on you know
there's 80 chance it came from the wet
market the bat 20 percent the lab or if
what what are your numbers predictions
[ __ ]
you know i just think
i'm i'm a nature guy so forgive me you
know i know a lot of people have passed
away so
rest in peace to the people that didn't
make it due to covert people that lost
their lives or their families their
businesses you know when i say [ __ ]
i don't mean disregard those things that
happen to those people because that's
you know that's real you know but like
a lot of stuff that was happening the
media wasn't helping us get real proper
information in the government or
whoever's in charge the cdc or who but
they didn't give us proper
information on what was actually
happening there was so much
stories going around you know so much
drama so much propaganda and everybody's
like stay home for two weeks and
everything will be fine and then here we
are two years later
we got three new variants gotcha we
gotta you know have
yeah yeah i don't know i mean at the
same time as well when they said um
i'm not a news guy
you